girl stop sending me this photo of a
trump rally with the sign thank you Lord
Jesus for president Trump it's not the
sign that worries me it's the baby that
look on his face says I have seen the
future and I want back in the womb new
rule don't judge how poorly the stock
market is doing based on the reaction of
the traders on the floor they flip out
over everything these guys pictured here
are just ordering coffee neuro Fox News
must capitalize on the current mood of
their viewers and create the very first
children's show anchor babies laugh and
learn along with hey sue swag and
Mohammed as they steal your hearts the
way they stole their citizenship they're
adorable and they're deportable
they're adoptable knurl someone must
explain to the Missouri woman who saw an
image of Donald Trump in it in a tub of
margarine that that's not an image
that's actually Donald Trump yes
it's true every night at midnight he
must return to his plastic tub and
assume his natural state a viscous oily
goo because Donald Trump is actually a
vampire made of vegetable oil condemned
to an eternity of anger tweeting until
somebody spreads him over corn
hero you can get mad at this fat kid for
trippin at the Museum and punching a
hole in a 350 year-old painting worth a
million and a half dollars but you've
got to give him credit he doesn't drop
his soda USA US
you